So, what's a bit? And a bit is the smallest
unit of information. So suppose I tell you that there are
two boxes. There's a green box and a blue box, and
in one of those two boxes, there's a gold star. And
it's equally likely to be in either the green box or
the blue box. One bit is the answer to one yes
or no question. So if you ask one yes or no
question, you ask, is the gold star in the green box,
then you get one bit back as the response. You get an
answer that's either yes or no. And when you learn which one it
is, that's one bit of information that allows you to go from
having two choices down to one choice and then you know, well, if
the answer was yes, the gold star's in the green box, that's
the one you should open. So when we think about bits in computing,
we don't usually call them yes or no. We call them 0
and 1. 0 more readily maps to no, and 1 to yes. So
I switched blue and green here. But we could
pick any two things. We could use green and blue.
We could use yes or no. If we have two
things And we can choose one of them. Knowing which
one to choose is one bit of information. So that's
what one bit can do. It allows us to decide
between two things. For the ancient Greeks network, maybe that's
all it could transmit. There was either the no bit,
which said there weren't any enemies arriving. Or if there was a
smoke signal, that was one bit saying, yes there is an enemy
arriving. So it's possible if it was only able to transmit that
1 message, that it only conveyed 1 bit of information. If all we
can do is send bits, we can send either a 0 or
a 1, or a yes or a no. But let's think of
it as 0 and 1s now. Can we send anything more interesting?
Can we just send one thing? And it turns out that we can
actually send everything that we want, just
using bits. So instead of just picking between
two boxes, now let's suppose there are four
boxes. So let's say, there's, a purple box,
and there's a dark red box. So now there're four boxes. There's still only one
gold star. So can we figure out which box the gold star is in with just yes,
no questions? Well one way to do that would be to ask
four questions, right? We could say is it in the green box?
We could ask is it in the purple box? We could ask
is it in the blue box and as long as we know there is
at least one gold star. We don't really need to ask if
it's in the dark red box, because if we got no for all
three of these well then we know the answer to that next question,
if we asked if it was in the red box, would be yes.
So here we needed up to three questions, to figure out which box the gold star
was in. Can we do better? So the question is, how many bits do we need to
find the gold star? And remember each bit
is the answer to one, yes or no question.
And we have four possible boxes and the
gold star could be any anyone of those four.